bonjour a tous ravie de vous retrouver ici
à bruxelles au coeur du parlement
européen pour ce nouveau numéro de
rappel d'eau et dans cette émission
nous irons en allemagne - petits partis
politiques
on ne la mort de l'euro alors les
allemands
sont-ils devenus eurosceptique c'est ce
que nous verrons avec notre invité mais
d'abord l'actualité panneaux solaires
chinois contre 20 français
la guerre commerciale at-elle déclaré
entre l'union européenne et la chine
c'est la question la semaine
la chine deuxième partenaire
économique de l'union européenne
derrière les etats-unis
en 2012 l'union européenne a
enregistré un déficit commercial de
156 milliards d'euros avec pékin
les produits chinois ils n'ont de
l'europe
vêtements électronique jouer service
ii ces panneaux solaires produits
exportés à très bas prix par les
fabricants chinois ils menacent
l'industrie photovoltaïque du vieux
continent trois cent mille emplois
pourraient disparaître
pour la protéger la commission
européenne propose d'imposer des droits
de douane sur les équipements venues de
chine
russell pointe du doigt les pratiques
déloyales de l'état chinois
soupçonnés de subventionner ces
grandes entreprises
mais coup de théâtre le 27 mai dernier
dit
dix-huit pays et refuse la taxe
anti-dumping et réclame une solution
négociée avec pékin parmi eux les
pays-bas le royaume-uni et surtout
l'allemagne seul état membre afficher
un excédent commercial avec pékin
le dossier revient après celle mardi 4
juin la commission européenne hausse le
ton
le plus écologique si nous jouons la
commission européenne a décidé à
l'unanimité je vais imposer des taxes
sur les importations de panneaux
solaires chinois et pour mettre fin aux
plans de prime sur le marché secondaire
le plus vieux
la mesure entrera en vigueur pour six
mois dès le 6 juin - une taxe de
conduire de 8% en moyenne s'appliquera
elle passera à 47 diagnostic % à
partir du 6 août si brussels eschyle à
trouver un terrain d'entente avec pékin
une décision qui risque de durcir un
peu plus le caractère commercial entre
les deux partenaires
pour parler de ce vrai sujet européen
nous sommes avec yannick jadot bonjour
bonjour
cette député européen europe-ecologie
les verts membre de la commission du
commerce international alors la
réaction
de pékin à ces annonces de bruxelles
n'a pas tardé puisque la chine a
annoncé pour 100 e de l'or a annoncé
le lancement dans quatre anti-dumping
contre les
européen
seiler cette fois la guerre est
déclarée
la guerre est déjà là la guerre
commerciale c'est avec entrain
grâce au dumping social au dumping
environnemental dumping fiscal un
dumping monétaire et on l'a vu sur les
panneaux photovoltaïques
des dizaines de milliards de dollars de
subventions
à son industrie photovoltaïque
c'est qu'on est dans une guerre
commerciale
et notamment sur des enjeux comme les
énergies nouvelles les énergies
renouvelables
pour tout le monde d enjeu
géostratégique majeur donc on est dans
cette guerre commerciale la question
aujourd'hui et c'est
est-ce que l'europe
se dote des moyens et des politiques
qui lui permettent d'affronter
ses partenaires commerciaux à la fois
dans des logiques de respect dans des
logiques des changes de partenariat
mais aussi de respect
et on a vu malheureusement dans ce
cas-là le rop totalement divisée c'est
ce que dit votre sujet la chine a quand
même réussi ce coup de maître de
diviser les états membres européen
et de diviser les acteurs de la filière
photovoltaïque est ce que cela
signifiait trop fort pour l'europe qui
est le prophète parce que divisés et
incapable de prendre des réactions %
enfin de réagir à temps
que la chine veut y avoir l'hégémonie
sur du secteur jeu stratégique
industriel
mais je le comprends
qu'il le fasse à coups de milliards
c'est leur logique
ce film est là en l'espèce le rock est
faible l'europe n'a pas de politique
industrielle c'est un déficit
de construction économique absolument
dramatique aujourd'hui on le voit sur la
sidérurgie on le voit sur l'automobile
et on le voit maintenant sur l'industrie
photovoltaïque et on a des états qui
essaye de jouer
leur intérêt
nationale leurs intérêts économiques
nationales
parfois de caumont voilà avec
l'allemagne contre l'intérêt
industriel les européens
on est dedans
les flamands ont souligné à l'afp
le pont pour le 50e anniversaire du
traité de l'elysée l'un des grands
sujets ça avait été une communauté
européenne de l'énergie constructeur
sur le couple franco-allemand et une sur
le remblai mana merkel
c'était promis des partenariats
industriels sur les énergies
renouvelables on voit que la réponse de
madame merkel c'est moi la communauté
européenne de l'énergie
que le couple
allemand
chinois
autour
de l'industrie dans les médias ce qui a
lieu de s'inquiéter pour cent pour le
plein air au pair a en tout cas
d'entente certains pour l'avenir de la
filière dans certains pays
je crois pas je crois pas parce que vous
savez la plupart des cépages qui sont
en chine sur les cépages français
vous avez vu l'offensive des chinois sur
un certain nombre de grands crus le
français et puis pas à ma connaissance
il n'y a pas des milliards d'euros
de subventions sur le secteur du vin
ce qui est arrivé à terme
c est à cet axe portable oui je crois
que c'est un coup de bluff ce n'est que
on sait bien que si on veut être
respecté par les chinois il faut
parfois par l'effort il faut savoir
taper du poing sur la table
c'est ce qu'a fait la commission
européenne
dans une situation très compliquée
parce qu'il était
comme je le disais l'allemagne a passé
un deal avec la chine mais la chine
a réussi à menacer suffisamment
un certain nombre de pays de reports et
on parle comme le ou la grèce et chypre
si vous votez pour les sanctions
nous vous sanctionneront nous-mêmes
sur les investissements
donc on voit la faiblesse de l'europe
tentant matière d'investissements
qu'en matière de politique merci à
l'industrie en même temps la commission
européenne était dense dans son rôle
elle a au moins annoncer des mesures
sérieuses pour boissons
elles sont pas suffisantes elle arrive
trop tard
les taxes les fameuses taxes elles sont
tardives ça fait pas un manque les
etats-unis ont imposé des droits de
douane jusqu'à 250%
elles sont provisoires ça c'est la
logique du système européen
pour cent la leçon insuffisante mans
corps une fois kante la commission fait
face à une majorité du conseil
qui est plutôt opposés à ces menaces
je trouve que la commission a été
relativement courageuse
ce cas de donner neuf mois donc acte
de la part de la commission européenne
c'est que les panneaux chinois sont
vendus sur les marchés mondiaux et donc
p
le marché européen à la moitié de
leurs coûts de revient comment
voulez-vous qu'une seule entreprise
européenne
résister à ça
vous voyez les entreprises européennes
tombait les zune
derrière les autres
alors que ce sont des entreprises
innovante performante compétitive qui
créent des emplois qui créent des
réseaux sur nos territoires dont compte
l'europe ne peut pas lâcher
cette industrie-là
à l'imaginer que l'europe ne soit une
économie de services
on a vu que ça marchera pas alors les
taxes sur les panneaux
la solaire chinois a lancé par m à la
commission européenne vont s'appliquer
pendant une durée de six mois en deux
temps avec 1 1 to have
d'abord de de 18% et ensuite de 47% ça
laisse quand même le temps pour eux à
l'europe pour négocier ce qu'on pensait
qu'il a une place pour la négociation
avec les chinois vu le contexte et les
divisions de dd européen
les le principe des mesures anti-dumping
ces deux roumaines de la concurrence
loyale
quand on connaît tous le moyens quand
elle devient déloyale
donc c'est pas normalement une mesure
définitive
céline sa gloire entraînée générés
des négociations pour que les
entreprises chinoises
il ne bénéficie plus ils
n'interviennent plus qu'avec ce dumping
là
que certains évoluer évaluer
milliards
de dollars ces considérations ce type
et d'industrie
et pour cent ou avec les autorités
chinoises pour que ça s'arrête à
partir du moment où ça s'arrête
y a aucun problème
mon sujet c'est pas de fermer le marché
européen
au panneau chinois c'est de faire en
sorte que la concurrence soit loyale
parce que je sais que les européens
wanda incroyable aux atouts à jouer sur
le photovoltaïque et c'est plein
d'entreprises qui sont en train de
tomber parce que l'europe ne réagissait
pas
eh bien merci beaucoup ri yannick jadot
de rater notre invité pour commenter
cette actualité chargé
l'actualité c'est aussi les
événements aux portes de l'hôtel de
rome certains ont pu re qui où les
affrontements se poursuivent entre eux
manifestants et forces de l'ordre la
turquie qui s'embrasera pendant un
instant avec les journalistes
la turquie met d'abord ces images qui
ont fait le tour des télés européenne
djasnabaille protestation touche
désormais les quatre plus grandes
villes de turquie sans aucun signe
d'essoufflement
mais ce sont les manifestations les plus
violentes que le gouvernement erdogan à
la fronde depuis qu'il est au pouvoir
l'étincelle qui a mis le feu aux
poudres si la décision du gouvernement
de construire un centre commercial
jean-jacques barthe d'istamboul cours
d'eau
les autres cela traduit le malaise des
défenseurs de la justice et de police
qui mise sur une croissance du pays
l'autoritarisme et du premier ministre
le premier ministre est au pouvoir
depuis onze ans
il n'aime guère la critique même la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme a
demandé de faire des efforts il se
défend d'islamiser la société
d'accueil différentes mesures mettent
de l'eau au moulin des opposants comme
celle de nantes interdit aux amoureux de
s'embrasser dans le métro ou encore le
rouge à lèvres trop prononcé banni
des visages les hôtesses de l'air
tellement décriée qu ils ont été
abandonnés
des manifestants qui nettoie tout de
même la place où ils se rassemblent
des scènes déjà vues ailleurs
l'an dernier
pour autant il n'est pas garanti que la
place taksim devienne la future place
tahrir de la turquie
d'abord parce qu'on voit sur ces images
la foule rassemblée aujourd'hui est
beaucoup moins importante
mais aussi parce que seules certaines
organisations d'extrême-gauche comme
celle-ci affiche la volonté de se
rassembler ici
la diaspora turque soutien les
manifestants turcs clients d'oracle des
familles suivent avec trois attitudes le
déroulement des manifestations
l'attachement aux valeurs data turc le
père de la turquie moderne très
important
et c'est tout un symbole pour cette
recherche de la pièce rare c'est
d'entraîner l'armée nationale
que se passe-t-il exactement en turquie
pour tenter de le comprendre nous sommes
avec une journaliste turque bonjour
bourgeois fut le sénat allane vous
êtes correspondante ici à brussels
pour eux plusieurs médias européen
r
on voit une foule très hétéroclite
avec des revendications diverses
qu'est-ce qu'elle demande à cette foule
de la place tahrir de la place taksim
pardon quelles sont les vraies raisons
de la colère
alors il faut savoir qu'à analyser les
événements qui ont éclaté à la
place taksim donc les manifestations
dia plusieurs raisons et à tenir une
seule raison
alors elle
les gens qui manifestent le sont
pour la majorité des cas
ils sont dérangés par le comportement
parfois
la façon de parler
du premier ministre les catalpas
adorable
parra la façon d'agir hold-up était
palpable dans l'âme
tous cas il y a ap
croissance économique à tout prix
c'est-à-dire des projets d'urbanisation
démesurée aniston boules ce qui me
dérange fortement les stambouliotes et
aussi le reste la turquie puisque c'est
un patrimoine ils seraient pas
protégées
pourvu sépare chaîne de l'islamisation
croissante de la société ce n'est pas
cela la vraie raison de france composée
par simplifiée pour 100 euros peut pas
dire que c'est une opposition entre
islam et laïcité veut que
citons parmi les manifestants on
retrouve aussi bien des environnementaux
des personnes qui vivent avec qui sont
contre le gouvernement les opposants
des conservateurs des personnes qui ont
voté pour la quitter
comme on a pu le voir les premiers jours
des manifestations il avait des femmes
voilées mais aussi des femmes non
voilées et de gaillac tous trois
étaient toutes toute personne quick est
contre le comportement déroulera le 9
se retrouvent dans la rue
est-ce qu'on peut parler d'eux
le printemps turc
c'est pas du tout ça
c'est pas comparable du tout à ce qui
s'est passé ce soir
la place tahrir cette fois en égypte
ça me fait aussi cette comparaison
alors c'est vrai que les images nous
rappellent un peu aller vers la place
tahrir
ahahah le printemps arabe le maire
peut absolument pas comparer par le
printemps arabe on peut pas dire qu'à
faire attention
tous cas il ya des élections
démocratiques qui ont lieu en turquie
depuis 1950 et l'on peut pas comparer la
turquie un pays arabe où il ya lieu
l'enquêté dirigée depuis 40 50 ans
par un régime dictatorial
et que dire des aînés aider et des
élections % en turquie
ils sont reconnus
alors en tant que démocrate par le
conseil de l'europe donc il faut voir
cela fait donc cesar gouvernement qui a
été prévu politiquement et
électoralement de manière légitime et
pour vous les héritages
laïque de la turquie moderne héritage
d'atatürk n'est pas menacée
l'héritage islamique
donc il faut où il faut que la maire de
roanne donc le premier ministre change
sage sa manière de se comporter de
s'exprimer envers la population et qu'il
ait plus de dialogue avec la population
tournage pourquoi réponse à notre
nation allemande site c'est tout à fait
ça qu'on nous reproche donc c'est un
peu plus de dialogue
peut-être faire des mdd référendum
pour savoir
qu'est-ce qu'on construit
et comment faire pour changer la ville
le visage à six voies d'istamboul à
quoi va ressembler et qu'on voit la
turquie donc c'est aussi un dialogue
c'est vraiment le dialogue d'ailleurs
but d'altérer une chemise premier
ministre art chercher l'apaisement en
s'excusant auprès de la population
pourquoi les manifestants blessés
et pour cent
vraiment lâchés à la turquie cherche
l'apaisement actuellement puisque ces
éléments ont fait des morts des jeunes
pourquoi la turquie justement des
négociations pour cent
d'adhésion
toujours hanté
cours depuis des années
avec l'union européenne et ce que ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui ça peut
remettre en cause
ces discussions
catherine ashton comme à las vegas
précisé ainsi les négociations ne
seront pas remises en cause
à cause des événements
qui ont eu lieu en turquie ces derniers
temps il faut savoir que les bongo
station avec l'union européenne ont
commencé en 2005
avec tout comme avec la la croix 6
en même temps que la croix si la 3ci va
bientôt entrer dans l'union européenne
mais la turquie est toujours à
à la traîne à la piétinent
pour plusieurs raisons l'union
européenne a aussi une part de
responsabilité là-dedans puisque
plusieurs chapitres ont été
débloqués par apple notamment la
france et chypre donc un coup d'avancé
la question des droits de l'homme qui
aide notamment sur la question des
droits de l'homme et comme denis
theurillat 10% e tour précédent
la dictature
que la turquie est que la culture
européenne devrait se retourner devrait
accorder plus attention et union
européenne et peut-être ouvrir les
chapitres sur les droits de l'homme la
justice ce qui est un point quand même
assez
et on reparlera très prochainement sans
doute cette de la situation en turquie
merci beaucoup
de plus une alarme d'avoir été avec
nous l émission se poursuit dans un
instant france abandonné et son invité
les députés allemands andréa choix
pour parler
la situation politique en allemagne et
notamment de l'arrivée un nouveau parti
alternative pour l'allemagne regardez
d'abord ce reportage à prendre pour
signer klaus et balises
je voudrais que ce qui signifie que les
peuples
dans ces quartiers populaires de
hambourg le docteur carney a fait
campagne pour le nouveau parti
eurosceptique
avec un actif pour la gagner
il a été déplacé en mer et plutôt
réceptifs
à suivre
sidney govou
je suis contre le rouergue et j'aimerais
revenir au-dessus marqué ma vie depuis
que nous avons l'euro
c'était vraiment devenue plus chère à
l'espagnole
parmi les signataires
beaucoup sont insatisfaits du
gouvernement pour l'heure les politiques
promettent le monde de la mer qu'elle
n'est plus capable de tenir l'allemagne
on a encore des projets publics pologne
de république tchèque et donc plus de
chômage et de misère ce n'est pas
comme nous
alors dans la ville fondatrice du parti
candidats sont sur le pied de guerre
avant les prochaines élections
fédérales en septembre
on a deux signatures cours en bourse
entre le normal qu'on a encore le centre
le contexte nous devons donc nous avons
besoin de 1600 signatures pour la liste
régionale et chaque candidat doit
réunir 250 signatures
le titre
car le football comme nous sommes six
candidats en nombre d'exposants en gros
trois mille signatures
* sort devrait pas par un concours de
chant
des signatures qui sont tout près
d'obtenir
car même si en allemagne le pays
européens les moins touchés par le
chômage et la crise
l'euroscepticisme gagner du terrain
alternatif pour l'allemagne entend
proposer une autre politique européenne
plus drastiques que celles d'un gala
merkel
pirate bay afin de lui
flo et au pire nous sommes vraiment
envie aux européens
mais nous sommes sûrs que l'europe elle
souffre de deux choses tout s tout
d'abord pour les lieux le groupe qui est
un problème pour l'europe pour apple
parce que cela ne marche pas c'est
gratuit et puis deuxièmement sacré la
commission européenne de bruxelles mais
qui n'est pas démocratique
bethesda azema balèze m'a démontré
avec
à l'origine du parti une pétition
d'une centaine de professeurs des
communes
critiquant la ligne laxiste et de
bruxelles
un programme protectionnistes et
libéral
pour une formation qui vise d'abord une
élite intellectuelle et les classes
professionnelles supérieures
pour ces universitaires une chose est
sûre
l'allemagne pays trop
pour le reste de l'europe
pour le moment elle est tout ce que nous
voulons désireux de concevoir le retour
de telle sorte qu'il n'y ait que les
seuls pays quant à ceux qui critiquent
israël est rentré dans le rugby
et cela veut dire que certains pays
méditerranéen m et bien non ça la
catalogne est un arrière goût amer aux
pme des otages
sorti avec brio crise de l'union
européenne l'idée fait son chemin chez
les allemands
selon un récent sondage ils sont plus
de la moitié contre le maintien de la
grèce dans l'euro
20% d'entre eux envisagent si un retour
au deutsche mark
pour entrer au parlement il faudra
quelqu'un actifs pour l'allemagne
tiennent 5% des votes la plupart des
sondages le placent plutôt autour des
3%
peu probable donc qui provoque un
bouleversement dans l'opinion car
demi-classe passé philemotte de plus on
ne pense pas qu'elle tentative sourde
chambas s'adressant à tout le monde
le nikkei
on aura une grosse beaucoup de personnes
se posent la question d'aller voter
pourrait se sentir concernés par les
propositions du parti vert et rouge
pourpre
ats les aubaines du tracé alternatif
sur deux échelons de départ que les
trains danger c'est pour la cedeao et le
spd les partis libéraux du fdp xavier
barral à trèbes droits de femmes
un rendez-vous avec des militants de les
rangs de la discipline le parti
majoritaire dans lequel américaine
pour rejoindre alternative que dans les
flandres
et si les nouveaux membres sont unanimes
sur le programme économique la
discussion s'envenime lorsqu'il aborde
les thèmes sociaux
la reine christine un peu mieux que je
pouvais nous sommes de culture
chrétienne du pays occidental nous ne
devons pas l'oublier
en france l italien et espagnol nous
sommes des chrétiens d'occident encore
partiels l'importation des catholiques
ont secoué venger listings je ne sais
quoi c'est notre culture notre tradition
si on se laisse de plus en plus en
veille dès le jour de sortie
alternatif pour l'allemagne restait
encore entre le conservatisme montant
et le populisme
le parti devrait définir sa ligne pour
de bon
lors de son premier congrès national au
mois de juin
un reportage signé claude baillet or
nous sommes sur ce plateau avec le
contraire ce sera un bon jour
bonjour vous êtes député européen
vous êtes allemands vous êtes du
groupe
quand on voit ce reportage marco sartor
aux gentils tiens parce que l'allemagne
ne serait pas en train de tombé du
côté des eurosceptiques endroit
je ne pense pas
le reportage a clairement une victime
qu'il ya un certain temps
des compliments
dans la population en allemagne
qui a probablement toujours été
présent
vous vous rappelez des mouvements
politiques
au moment de l'introduction de l'euro
qui sont échouées
avec moins d'un pour son rôle dans les
selon l'allemagne
et donc je pense
kloten 6 les parties
qui défend d'euros
ce matin expliquer mieux ce qu'ils ont
fait ce qu'ils veulent faire
une bataille qu'on peut gagner
on a comme l'impression que
ce que disent les allemands certains
seulement tout cas dire on paye trop
pour les autres on paie trop pour les
crêtes complète pour pouvoir les
portugais et les espagnols et cetera
c'est quand même quelque chose qui a un
écolo en allemagne
oui mais moi je viens de baldur's the
dark c'est le sud-est de l'allemagne
et les jambes dans ma région dans ma
circonscription se plaignent depuis des
cinquantaine d'années complet trop pour
les autres allemands
on était tous qu'on a été toujours un
pays un blanc d'oeuf
qui payer pour les autres lecteurs
donc ce système de transfert est
présent en allemagne et donc % et je
connais le 7 e ce mécontentement et
c'est pas quelque chose de nouveau
c'est vrai que la communication de la
politique de l'euro
n'a pas été parfaite mais c'est aussi
un sujet très complexe de communication
est à fait
page vers le meuble l'allemagne est le
premier contributeur à la foire sur le
fonctionnement de l'union européenne
ces petits pays le plus le pouvoir aider
les les pilleurs
en en difficulté donc
la communication qui était pas
excellente c'est pas une réalité celle
citoyens j'imagine ça va
mais c'est aussi un fait positif que
l'allemagne a retrouvé cette force
d'être en mesure
c'est contribuer
au bien-être eneurope de contribuer à
des politiques de réformes pourtant
l'europe entière il ya dix ans
au mans on avait eu du mal à s'imaginer
tous ces politiques qui sont maintenant
mises en place tous ses réformes donc
je pense on a vu beaucoup de succès
jusque maintenant malheureusement c'est
pas encore pas sensible des gens on a
pression qu'ils ont mis qui sont mis
dans des problèmes m aujourd'hui odette
penser que c'est quelque chose de gai
réformes sont quelque chose de de
positif mais je crois fortement que au
long terme il va s'avérer que c'était
des réformes nécessaires et positives
pour les populations
à l'encontre reportage plus belle en
contre un journaliste allemand
il a une remarquable en faire nancy doit
savoir ce que vous en pensez dans les
côtes
à l'abbaye explique ps
dehors projet de statistiques qui
laissent à penser que le phénomène
des petits partis un potentiel prendre
du pouvoir aux grandes formations
le grison plus il joue sur le sentiment
anti-européen griffin les allemands
semblent désorientés ils n'aiment pas
ils ne savent pas exactement combien la
route le rock laissé seul argument
principal d'alternative sur d'autres
chantiers dans la salle où mène peas
même si le fait de rejoindre
voyez les élections importante
évidemment mois de septembre importante
pour l'allemagne
et pour madame merkel est ce que vous
pensez que ce qui est dit l'arrêt
presque bon évidemment ce que ce parti
ne sera pas majoritaire masque
l'audition des petits partis comme ça
ça peut mettre
côté des grands partis comme
thomas merkel en difficulté
moi je je n'y crois pas
il est vrai que tel au mena
par la volonté politique
en allemagne d'ailleurs en compte non
plus en france
de dire la vérité
babès et de population
en ouvrant de l'an 2100
comptera encore pour 5 portes pour se
rendre de la population mondiale
avec 5% de la population mondiale vous
l'avez je suis mort rien à dire
et donc peu importe où vous habitez à
paris ou à berlin
donc la perspective devant laquelle nous
nous trouvons c'est une perspective à
long terme ou l'europe bah baisser
en poids politique en pointe économique
donc pour trouver des solutions à cela
il faut qu'on travaille ensemble
que l'europe ait une pique une
nécessité
pour nous défendre à nouveau et je
pense qu'on n'a pas levé la force
politique de le dire de cette clarté
et ça ment parce que l'europe or
ker
de la campagne électorale en allemagne
il peut être pas l'europe mais l'euro
et puis je trouve ça c'est le premier
point
et puis une à une marque
d'identification des européens dans
tous les pays européens m
on peut discuter aujourd'hui sur la
solution la crise de l'euro
la crise des dettes
avant l'euro
et ça c'est quelque chose qui se
discute n'importe où l'europe et 5000
autres
est en train de devenir plusieurs
opéras
qu'on honore on ne l'a pas de pop en
servant
lors de la dernière campagne
électorale en france pour l'élection
présidentielle
l'europe a été assez absente
finalement
parce que si on sait que quand on parle
de l'europe pouvoir on ne gagne pas de
voix au contraire on a même plutôt
tendance en terre
parce que ça va être quand même un
peu la même chose ou est-ce que madame
merkel
donc l partie appartenait à son parti
est ce que
e ce code est va mettre ça en avant les
boeufs les bienfaits de l'euro ce que
sait quelque chose parce que c'est un
discours révolte qu'elle va tenir
je pense qu'elle est convaincue
qui via des boutiques la défaite
positifs de l'euro pour l'allemagne et
des faits économique et est aussi
financier positif pour l'allemagne mais
il est très difficile d'expliquer
s'arrogeant
car prendre aux etats-unis ont dit
entre le texas selon coutou politiqué
et locales et donc les leslie les
domaines politique et son passé
lointain sont très difficiles à
expliquer ces quatre c'est un fait
et malheureusement je crains qu'on va
aussi se porter à se faire
elle dans la campagne électorale en
allemagne
dernière question vous êtes à l'aise
vous êtes surtout député l'euro perd
à ce que vous avez le sentiment que
ce qui se passe en allemagne avec
alternatif a battu nantes
et révélateur de ce qui se passe dans
d'autres pays
européen avec la montée de populisme
absolument il ya rarement de man en dans
tous les pays de l'europe m un certain
nombre de personnes de gauche
extrême-gauche taux de 3 d'extrême
droite
et donc je pense que c'était rien de
vraiment pour 100 e cessez aucune chose
qui doit nous faire peur
ça vous êtes vous inquiète pas pour
la prochaine saison européenne ça
m'inquiète pas si on a vu arriver à
expliquer pourquoi nous faisons tout ça
merci embrasse pas d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
c'est la fin en europe le dos on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine et d'ici
là bonne suite de programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires halte-là